[Musica]
il 28 marzo del 2011 in Armenia
all'improvviso internet smette di
funzionare sono irraggiungibili tutti i
siti web è impossibile inviare qualsiasi
tipo di messaggio impossibile fare
qualsiasi tipo di operazione online il
paese si ferma per 12 lunghissime ore
emergono ovviamente le prime ipotesi
sarà stato un attacco di hacker
internazionale un atto ostile di un
governo nemico un atto terroristico
dopo qualche giorno il mistero viene
risolto a mettere in ginocchio un paese
è stata questa signora qui
signora aiasan 75 anni residente nel
villaggio georgiano di armadi al confine
tra Georgia e Armenia la signora
cercando rame nei terreni intorno alla
propria abitazione a un certo punto con
una sega ha tranciato l'unico cavo sul
quale poggiava l'intera rete internet
dell'Armenia
quando la polizia la fermata la signora
si è giustificata dicendo io non so
neanche cosa sia internet e le crediamo
direi No ma noi in realtà ma noi lo
sappiamo che cos'è internet e come
funziona
Ecco questo episodio che vi ho
raccontato a mio avviso è molto
emblematico ci racconta in particolare
due aspetti Il primo è l'immensa
fragilità della tecnologia che ha
rivoluzionato le nostre vite basta una
signora con una sega per mandare offline
un'intero paese Il secondo aspetto è
quello che a me piace definire la
fisicità di internet
Cloud WiFi wireless quando pensiamo alla
rete spesso immaginiamo qualcosa di
etereo onde che si muovono nello spazio
in realtà non è così oltre il 95% delle
comunicazioni online Oggi passa
attraverso cavi to be spesso piccoli
come quelli che utilizziamo per
innaffiare i nostri giardini
oltre un milione di chilometri di questi
tubi passano sotto i mari
i cavi sottomarini sono probabilmente
una delle più avanzate infrastrutture
globali mai realizzate dall'uomo Eppure
solamente gli addetti ai lavori spesso
ne conoscono l'esistenza
intere economie dei paesi le industrie
automatizzate 4.0 gli scambi commerciali
le transazioni finanziarie tutto oggi
passa dentro quei cavi per darvi un'idea
è stato stimato che ogni giorno lì
dentro si muovono transazioni
finanziarie per circa
180.000 miliardi di dollari e il doppio
del PIL del Giappone
ogni singolo giorno
c'è un vecchio adagio della Geopolitica
tradizionale che è valido ancora oggi
che dice chi controlla i Mari controlla
il mondo proviamo a riaggiornarlo a
questo punto chi controlla i cavi
Controlla il mondo
vale la pena chiedersi ma chi li
controlla Allora questi cavi
il primo cavo in fibra ottica che sono i
cavi quelli a tecnologia più recente è
stato posato nel 1988
da una società di telecomunicazioni la
TNT un gigante americano delle
telecomunicazioni e per anni sono state
queste aziende le principali
protagoniste della realizzazione della
posa dei cavi sottomarini oggi non è più
così oggi tra i principali investitori
nella realizzazione dei cavi di internet
C'è una società della quale
probabilmente avete già sentito il nome
si chiama Google è un famoso motore di
ricerca ma non fa solo il motore di
ricerca
guardate questa mappa Questi sono i cavi
di Google nel mondo
impressionante uno degli ultimi cavi che
Google ha realizzato e attivato si
chiama Dion e collega gli Stati Uniti
con la Francia passando per 6000 km
sotto l'Atlantico è un cavo che in
termini di tecnologia di velocità ha
spodestato Il cavo che precedentemente
aveva il primato era quello più avanzato
che si chiamava si chiamava tuttora
marea marea Lo ha realizzato
una società della quale anche qui
Immagino il nome vi suonerà familiare
meta ovvero Facebook così come in giro
per il mondo e per i mari ci sono cavi
realizzati da Microsoft da Amazon Huawei
eccetera eccetera Cioè questo è quello
che è successo negli ultimi anni che le
società le grandi piattaforme che un
tempo si avvalevano dei cavi realizzati
dalle aziende di telecomunicazione
spesso lo sottolineo a controllo
pubblico Ebbene queste piattaforme che
oggi ci danno l'e-commerce i social
media i motori di ricerca oggi in questi
cavi
se li realizzano da soli e li
controllano da soli
Questo è quello che è successo abbiamo
pensato per anni ad una rete libera in
realtà questa rete è molto condizionata
è condizionata da due attori
fondamentali Il primo lo abbiamo appena
visto sono le grandi multinazionali del
Tek quelle che controllano i cavi
saranno sempre di più loro in futuro a
decidere dove arriverà internet e A che
velocità arriverà poi c'è un altro
protagonista di questa che è a mio
avviso una vera e propria competizione
Geopolitica ovvero gli stati
e le loro posizioni sempre più ispirate
a quella che viene definita la
cosiddetta sovranità digitale per capire
la sovranità digitale facciamo un
piccolo passo indietro andiamo in Russia
dicembre 2019 il governo di Mosca
annuncia la realizzazione del primo test
su quella che poi i media chiameranno la
runet l'internet Russo praticamente
autonomo rispetto all'internet mondiale
in molti hanno letto in questa scelta di
Mosca la volontà ovviamente di staccarsi
dai grandi server americani altri ci
hanno letto anche il tentativo di
rendere ancora più stringente il
controllo sui contenuti postati dai
cittadini russi
Il fatto è che l'idea di avere una
propria internet che funzioni appunto
indipendentemente dall'internet globale
oggi viene sempre di più visto dai
governi come un vantaggio strategico
Soprattutto soprattutto
in un periodo in cui ahimè sono tornati
a soffiare tragici 20 di guerra pensiamo
al conflitto in Ucraina
Allora non so se qualcuno di voi durante
qualche
romantica notte d'estate ha visto nel
cielo queste luci qui
non sono extraterrestri ma sono i
satelliti starlink
i satelliti starlink che servono proprio
per dare connessione internet
satellitare sono realizzati da una
società che si chiama spacex di un
signore che si chiama elon musk anche
questo è un nome che probabilmente
avrete sentito ne girano intorno
all'orbita circa 3.000 ora
elon musk durante il conflitto in
Ucraina ha donato agli ucraini circa
15.000 kit per connettersi ai suoi
satelliti la iniziativa ammirevole però
Pensiamoci bene
oggi
le linee di comunicazione di un paese
possono dipendere da un'azienda da un
imprenditore che ti regala i kit domani
magari ti stacca internet Ecco dove
nasce la volontà di rendersi più
autonomi questa idea dell'internet
Sovrana
e Qual è lo stato che sta lavorando di
più da anni sulla realizzazione della
propria internet sovrana è la Cina in
Cina Abbiamo quello che si chiama il
Great firewall No una sorta di Grande
Muraglia digitale all'interno della
quale il controllo sui siti sulle app
sulle aziende tecnologiche e sui
contenuti postati dai cittadini è sempre
più sofisticato e pervasivo l'idea
Dunque di una internet sovrana non è
nuova è nuovo invece il suo radicarsi
negli ultimi anni anche tra varie
democrazie del mondo compresi alcuni
governi europei
vi faccio vedere la home page del
Ministero dell'Economia francese
ha un nome più lungo in realtà si chiama
Ministero dell'Economia delle Finanze e
della sovranità industriale e numerica
digitale ovvero il termine sovranità
digitale all'interno del nome stesso di
un ministero
il digitale ha cambiato il mondo lo
sappiamo no ha costruito un mondo fatto
di dati che vanno senza dubbio governati
con normative procedure istituzioni le
intenzioni di alcuni paesi di ad esempio
avere delle legislazioni più stringenti
sui dati dei propri cittadini oppure
l'idea di avere un Cloud Nazionale
questa intenzioni sono legittime e
comprensibili però attenzione
perché aprono la strada ad una
pericolosa deriva la rete quella che
abbatte i confini geografici i confini
culturali potrebbe ben presto essere
un'utopia
sono passati oltre 30 anni eh dalla
caduta di questo muro qui il muro di
Berlino
potremmo ben presto ritrovarci a vivere
in un mondo fatto di nuovi muri stavolta
muri digitali
sovranità digitale che si trasforma
nella sua deriva il sovranismo digitale
per cercare di arginare questa questa
deriva la Commissione Europea sta
lavorando da tempo alla creazione di una
sorta di
mercato unico dei dati con normative
comunitarie per tutelare i diritti dei
cittadini europei Ecco questa
Eventualmente potrebbe essere una strada
da seguire quella di accordi tra governi
non singoli governi che si tirano su
muri e si fanno le proprie reti Internet
l'idea della sovranità digitale Europea
è un'idea positiva Perché può diventare
strumento per tutelare i diritti dei
cittadini ma allo stesso tempo anche per
promuovere quei principi di libertà di
democrazia della quale l'Europa si fa e
si deve fare porta
internet sta cambiando Eh potrebbe
essere molto diverso in futuro da quello
che è oggi dominato da poche grandi
multinazionali e segnato da confine
nazionali ecco per evitare questo
scenario dobbiamo cercare di avere anche
noi un ruolo attivo in generale la
società civile Dobbiamo informarci di
più su ciò che avviene dietro la rete
Dobbiamo comprendere quelle che
attenzione potrebbero sembrare solamente
tecnologie ma non lo sono hanno a che
fare con la vita di tutti i giorni
dobbiamo lavorare insieme dobbiamo fare
pressione sui governi e sulle grandi
multinazionali per arrivare ad una nuova
internet che sia Democratica inclusiva
rappresentativa dei diritti rispettosa
together
dobbiamo evitare che l'evoluzione di
internet sia guidata dagli interessi
geopolitici dei governi ed economici
delle multinazionali dobbiamo lavorare
insieme together
Guardate se
se un giorno internet sarà diverso da
come lo abbiamo immaginato da come lo
abbiamo sognato sarà una grandissima
sconfitta per tutti noi quella magari di
giustificarci come la signora aiazan Ah
ma io non sapevo nemmeno cosa fosse o
come funzionasse internet grazie
[Applauso]